metal music ought to be synonymous with
first-person shooters considering the
original doom is perhaps the most
influential fps of all time that game's
frenetic demon slaying was accompanied
by the iconic sounds of 32-bit heavy
metal riffs and high-tempo drums but the
marriage between the two never really
caught on outside of shooters like quake
killing floor 2 and mick gordon's
phenomenal work on the most recent doom
games metal hellsinger isn't likely to
buck that trend but this rhythm based
fps from swedish developer the outsiders
puts metal front and center as the most
crucial aspect of his high octane
gameplay
[Music]
at first glance metal hellsinger may
look like little more than an imitation
of 2016's doom from the general demon
killing and hell inspired aesthetic
right down to the searing pace of its
action doom is an obvious inspiration
and apt comparison but metal hellsinger
adds an extra layer of depth to his
shooting by structuring all of its
moving parts around music you play as a
demon who's fighting through hell on a
revenge mission and you deal more damage
by shooting enemies to the beat of a
song the more precise you are about
keeping rhythm the more your fury
multiplier will grow and the more your
overall score and damage output will
increase to help you achieve this there
are pulsating icons on either side of
the crosshairs that match up with the
rhythm of the song if you're on beat
you'll be graded with either a good or
perfect attack with the letter dealing
the most damage and adding more to both
your fury and score
[Music]
beyond the nitty gritty of its mechanics
however killing demons in time to a
song's rhythm is just incredibly
satisfying there's an added oomph to the
sound of your weapon when you're on beat
and increasing your fury has a direct
impact on the music too as the
multiplier escalates from 1 times up to
16 times the music builds until
eventually reaching a rip-roaring
crescendo as the vocals kick in and the
song's full arrangement is unleashed
battering your eardrums were the kind of
gut rule vocals that perfectly fit the
game's demonic aesthetic
[Music]
it feels like you're the driving force
propelling the song forward with each
kill and reaching this point and
maintaining it requires you to fall into
a zen-like flow where shooting to the
beat almost becomes second nature bpm
bullets per minute scratched a similar
itch but metal hellsinger refines the
concept and is unlike anything i've ever
played especially when you compare it to
the moment-to-moment gameplay of
traditional first-person shooters
instead of shooting at every moment
possible you have to do it when it makes
sense musically even dashing and
reloading in time with the beat builds
fury as do the doom style executions
that reward you with health you're
essentially rewiring your brain but it's
so intuitive and responsive that when it
all clicks there are a few shooters
quite as gratifying it helps of course
that the soundtrack absolutely shreds
all the music in metal hellsinger is
composed by the duo that form two
feathers there's also an all-star
selection of metal vocalists lending
their talents to metal hellsinger
getting to hear new material from some
of the best vocalists in the genre is a
treat especially when it's so
intertwined with the gameplay each level
has an original song associated with it
and they run the game of different
styles and subgenres of metal this adds
variety but also feels like a nod to the
various vocalists involved for instance
burial at night the song featuring
tatiana shmaeluk has some prominent bass
slapping that's reminiscent of many
ginger songs
while the alyssa white glues track
features harmonized guitars and the
catchiest chorus of the
been soundtrack for you
[Music]
of the songs are excellent though to the
point where i could happily listen to
the full soundtrack outside of the game
the songs are somewhat limited by the
games can see so don't expect any thrash
metal or tempo and time signature
changes from the drums altering the
consistent beat that runs through each
track would make metal helsing an ion
impossible to play your arsenal of
weapons does change how often you can
fire though lending each firearm its own
sort of cadence the persephone shotgun
for instance has a slower rate of fire
so it can only shoot on every other beat
while the hounds dual revolvers can fire
on every single beat until you need to
reload this makes each weapon feel like
an instrument in and of itself and the
sounds they make whether it's the
rewarding crunch that accompanies each
perfectly timed shot or the musicality
of every weapons reload only reinforces
the sentiment every aspect of metal
hellsinger makes you feel connected to
the music while you're in rhythm you'll
notice pyro bursting out from the floor
like you're in the middle of a ramstein
concert and some of the enemies pulsate
with an orange glow along with the beat
these are nice touches that make the
game world feel more reactive to your
performance but the level of design
itself is rather formulaic each level
consists of moving from one combat arena
to the next until you eventually face
off against the boss maybe deviating
from this formula would have proven
problematic considering the rhythmic
nature of the whole game but it does
make your trek through the bowels of
hell feel rather samey the same can be
said of the boss fights too as each one
pits you against the same skeletal bat
like creature with only visual
fluctuations occurring on its head each
one peppers you with projectiles you
need to evade before summoning a wave of
enemies and while this is exciting the
first time it doesn't take long before
each boss battle is little more than a
bland footnote at the end of every level
i completed metal helsing in four hours
so at least these issues aren't
compounded by the concept being
stretched too thin despite its short
duration however the scoring system and
the inclusion of leaderboards adds a lot
of replayability especially since the
game functions more like a dedicated
rhythm game than a shooter with musical
elements tacked on it's easy to fall
into a rewarding loop built around
improving your score and moving up the
leaderboards that's not too dissimilar
from playing something like guitar hero
there's also an interesting score
breakdown at the end of each level that
shows different stats like the
percentage of the level you spent at 16
times fury the number of kills you
achieved on beat or the longest hit
streak you musted this shows that areas
you can potentially improve upon next
time round but also factors into the
game's torments sigils and boons there's
also a story that's told via static
cutscenes in between levels it's a campy
tale of revenge featuring warring
skeletons falling angels and the
southern drawl of troy baker's narration
the latter gives the narrative some life
and the illustrations used throughout
make it feel like you're traveling
through a dl album cover it's neither
bad nor good it just kind of exists to
add some meaning to all of the wonton
demon slaying
the old wasn't gonna be able to ignore
us
things have gone too far
when things go too far in him
well
then it gets complicated
you know that rare moment in video games
where your actions unintentionally line
up with the music you're listening to
whether it's the game's soundtrack or
your own metal hellsinger bottles up
that magic feeling and repeats it over
and over again without the satisfaction
ever fading the interplay between his
chuggy metal soundtrack and high octane
gameplay is phenomenal and quite unlike
anything else i've ever played it
stumbles at times and these issues hold
it back from reaching rob halford as
kites by its execution of an idea and
the way this transforms the moment to
moment action of a shooter into a
rhythmic slaughter props up any of its
faults if mettle hellsinger is a metal
album come to life then i can't wait for
this band's sophomore effort
[Music]
all day